hello reject nation I'm Greg
I'm John Alvarado cat Alvarado over here
with us today
cat Alvarado she is going to be on the
FN x TV channel this Friday March 23rd
at 9 p.m. performing comedy guys check
your cable listings to make sure you
have the channel so you can catch this
lovely face doing some lovely comedy on
television down there by my feet yeah
that's funny them to cross joke earlier
video but hey it's the worst frege's
enum there right hey cat have you ever
heard of a comedic rapper named little
Dickie no I haven't well he is
sensational on the internet and he has a
new video out right now a comedy rap
video I think it's a funny one sometimes
he does a serious song you ready to
watch this with us we're gonna introduce
you to little Dickie Dickie but you're
gonna be reexpose to Chris Brown's
that's gonna be
[Music]
so I'm between the between the so much
more than me people are so good at
dancing
sometimes I really wish I could be
somebody else
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was a little joke at the end little
dickie that was a lame one well you know
what he's got four and a half minutes of
other jokes in there a whole rap
creative song you gotta give him some
credit there I give him a B+ yeah it's a
whole great off because he included
Chris Brown good challenge once I got
past you know I I don't know what to do
at this moment I'm like yeah it was
pretty funny and like - the things that
I know is pretty funny and and it was a
bit self-aware he at least acknowledges
like you know oh I'm little Dicky and
now nobody's bugging me about my
controversial controversial savety says
yeah which I'm not really qualified to
have this conversation incomplete at the
moment but you know hey I've never liked
Chris Brown's music I've never like I've
never been like man I hate it I just
never liked it and then after all that
controversial past stuff I especially
don't respect I looked at this is like
little Dickies random music video even
though I know how I feel about Chris
Brown I do gotta say that like this [ __ ]
have any cracking up oh yes I was still
like I'll set aside my personal not
liking Chris Brown feelings to decide to
enjoy this random bit of video and
there's like crazy celebrity appearances
in there uh give an edge here the Freaky
Friday concept in a rap song about
switching bodies with a less famous
person with a super famous person I
thought is a really funny yeah like the
jokes in here were really funny and the
playout in the video itself are all
pretty amusing especially I'm watching
him trying to track himself down and
like why is my mom calling ya and stuff
like that yeah it's like I don't know if
I would just listen to this song but the
video in unison with this song I thought
was what was quite amusing yeah I think
they had good timing too with switching
it but like I love myself you need a
change at some point you can only do so
many jokes yeah yeah yeah things gonna
be a fair little Dickies part when he's
actually rapping is better at rapping
and is funnier too you can set aside
this Chris Brown personal feelings to
the side this is still a little Dicky
song for the most part you know yeah
it's just weird timing for I mean it's
never gonna be good timing have Chris
Brown appear in the video but especially
now with everything that's been going on
with female empowerment and women's
rights and all that and also would that
snapchat snapchat was like a whole yeah
the whole supposedly snapchat lost like
millions millions of dollars and their
stock because of that around every right
to get pissed off about that it's just
like strange timing for this but I'm
able to just go now put to the side
right now and enjoy the video
okay it's not like the Chris Brown thing
just came out and like we'll take he was
already in the process of making this
and and couldn't really find someone
else in time and like oh no like this
happened what 10 freakin years
was it ten years ago it's a while
there's many years ago sometime yeah
very young could've done a better choice
like maybe he couldn't find anyone else
or maybe it had to be a fillable rapper
it was kind of weird with Curtis Browns
career because Chris Brown's like career
never taint after that incident it
didn't seem to really affect his career
so it seemed like the public just kind
of forgave him for it kind of wonder
it's like Donald Trump saw Chris Brown's
career not completely crash and said I
could do this I can run for president
this is it thank you Chris Brown I don't
know much about Chris Brown's life and
it has been a long time I can't speak to
what he's done to atone for anything or
to change or to improve and so without
that information I kind of land here in
no-man's land where I'm like yeah just
in the isolated context of this video I
think this is very funny in the grander
scheme of things I wouldn't ask Chris
Brown be on my track I thought it was
funny to subscribe to the real rejects
quick that notification bell and cat
Alvarado you can catch her on FNX
Channel this Friday at 9:00 p.m. March
23rd performing comedy on television
make a catch that's me and follow me at
the cat Alvarado on Twitter Instagram
you know it